the selection is over and there's a new
president but the election hasn't been
about the winner it hasn't been about
Donald Trump it hasn't been about
Hillary Clinton this election it's been
about the deaths of the American
political party consider for instance
the GOP the Republicans this election
have shown themselves unable to mobilize
and inspire their base without resorting
to pure demagoguery and fear there's
nothing about Donald Trump that made him
qualified to be President but he
presented a vision to essentially a
white America that sees itself as no
longer in control of the narrative of
this country's history its present and
definitely not its future so when Donald
Trump said let's make America great
again the immediate question so many
asked was well for who and the
Republicans didn't stop him they didn't
want to sure they showed outrage here
and there but they saw him inspire and
move their base in such a way that they
knew he would be the strongest candidate
they could put forward then there's a
democratic party in a selection the
Democrats really showed how their
purpose is the preservation of the power
of the elite at any cost there was no
space for candidate like Bernie Sanders
look at the Podesta emails the
incredible thing about John Podesta
emails was that they offered a blueprint
on how this country is run through big
power big money and Podesta was
clinton's presidential campaign chair so
you find in those emails a total lack of
connection to the people the Democratic
Party poises itself as representing so
this election had a winner but this
election was also the death of the
American political party because
everything ugly about those two parties
that has existed for so long behind the
scenes is all out there now sure the
system can't protect the people it was
never built to protect but this election
changed this country just as a changing
country made this election what it was
so how do you even begin to rebuild a
political system with a crumbling
legitimacy and a leadership that cares
more about staying in power than serving
its citizens